ils étaient 14 candidats à recevoir leur
diplôme le 20 décembre 2023 au ski cube
pour la 3e année consécutive le
programme entrepreneuriat pour tous
formait et accompagn des porteurs de
projets l'objectif révéler leur
potentiel et les aider à s'intégrer à
l'écosystème local euh l'idée c'était de
de pouvoir toucher un public qui est un
petit peu en dehors des dispositifs
traditionnels d'accompagnement et l'idée
c'est vraiment de les accompagner dans
leur parcours pour créer leur entreprise
de septembre à décembre 2023 les
participants ont pu bénéficier de 205 de
formation gratuite un soutien essentiel
pour Amel et Sandrine qui partait de
zéro on a fait appel à entrepreneuriat
pour tous parce que on avait un concept
et un projet et tout ce qui allit autour
donc le statut
juridique le prix la gestion de
l'entreprise tout ça ça nous échappait
et on a décidé de se faire entourer et
on a bien fait puisque notre projet n'a
rien à voir avec il y a 3 mois ça nous
apporté beaucoup de confiance en fait on
avait besoin aussi qu'on nous disent que
c'était faisable et pour pour que ce
soit faisable il faut des éléments il
faut une sécurité et on l'a pu
l'acquérir ici à la ski cuube j'ai
intégré entrepreneuriat pour tous au ski
cuube parce que j'avais besoin d'un coup
de pouce parce que l'entrepreneuriat
c'est pas quelque
chose que j'ai pu faire auparavant du
coup ça m'a permis là pendant 3 mois et
demi d'avoir des connaissances sur un
peu sur tous les aspects de la création
d' entreprise donc c'était très
enrichiss l'année dernière Isabelle Bor
a elle aussi pu bénéficier du programme
entrepreneuriat pour tous un programme
qui lui a donné toutes les clés
nécessaire pour fonder son cabinet de
sophrologie basé à morpa je pense que ça
m'a vraiment aidé à savoir quoi faire à
quel moment quels étaient les choses les
plus importantes à mettre en place dans
un premier temps puis après
et faire les choses étape par étape et à
ne pas balayer certaines choses c'estàd
par exemple bilan prévisionnel je pense
que j'auris peut-être pas fait si
j'avais pas fait la formation où
j'aurais pas su l'importance de l'étude
de marché voilà je pense qu' il y a des
étapes que j'aurais peut-être sauter si
je n'avais pas fait le le programme
cette année six entreprises ont déjà été
créées rendez-vous en 2024 pour le
lancement de la 4e promotion